E aí
[Música]
eu era uma vez um garfo
e ágil simpático confiável Generoso
significava
um de boca aberta para ele
e o gatinho trabalhava em um restaurante
fazer uma atividade que ninguém
conseguia fazer igual a ele a colher
tentava mas era muito desengonçado a
faca queria mas era muito perigosa só o
garfo tinha um formato certo não há
bocado Mais Um Dia Depois de tanto levar
comida para lá e para cá o garfinho
entrou numa Crise existencial depois de
tantos anos trabalhando começou achar
que estava perdendo tempo na vida ele
olhava sua amiga a boia inflável de
natação e vi aquelas salvar vidas de
crianças ele também olhava escova de
dente e que aquela melhorava vida dos
seus donos
eu nem olhava o celular e via que era
usado o tempo todo enquanto o gás só
fazia o carreto do arroz de vez em
quando para lá e para cá um servicinho
Logístico um trabalho chato que nunca
traria sucesso
o sucesso gatinho
eu posso fazer um pedido para você pense
agora uma pessoa mais bem-sucedida que
você conhece
e quem é que você lembra que tem mais
sucesso no trabalho normalmente pensamos
primeiro em pessoas que são muito ricas
famosas ou poderosos não é
é isso mostra que o nosso conceito de
sucesso está muito ligado com pessoas
que crescem rápido na carreira sai em
capas de revista ou tem muitos
seguidores em redes sociais Mas será que
isso é sucesso de verdade amigo garfinho
um dia você vai ficar velhinho
e talvez você fique grisalho Talvez um
pouco enrugadinho talvez até usa uma
bengalinha quando isso acontecer você
olhar para trás
e o que que você gostaria de ver
E como você vai considerar que você fez
a coisa certa na vida essa é uma
discussão que passa por tudo na nossa
agenda relacionamentos família Hobby
saúde e passa muito fortemente para o
nosso trabalho porque a gente gasta mais
da metade da vida trabalhando só
imaginou isso faz a conta mais da metade
do seu tempo acordado você tá
trabalhando
e por isso insisto Quais são os seus
sonhos profissionais
e para que você acorda cedo todo dia
para que
e vamos uma brincadeira agora vou fazer
de conta que chegou aqui um gênio da
lâmpada olha aí que gênio bonitão hein
esse gênio vai te dar 10 opções e não
vai deixar você escolher uma delas você
pode escolher qualquer uma Mas você vai
ter que abrir mão das outras combinada
Olha só as opções primeira delas você
pode escolher só trabalhar com algo que
você gosta muito para o resto da sua
vida segunda opção é fazer algo Impact
muito a sua geração terceira opção é
conseguir gastar mais tempo com a sua
família do que trabalhando ou ainda se
reconhecido mundialmente pelo seu
trabalho ou ainda sempre trabalhar por
um propósito maior só trabalhar com
chefes e clientes que você acha legais
fica a bilionário
se você famoso muito famoso consegui se
aposentar cedo ou faliram concorrente
Quando essas opções você escolheria eu
fiquei tão curioso com essa enquete que
fiz uma pesquisa de verdade com ajuda da
provokers Nós entrevistamos quase mil
trabalhadores brasileiros também que
Eles responderam isso aqui ó a maior
parte das pessoas escolheu alternativa
quero ficar bilionário que significa que
muita gente toparia trabalhar com chefes
chatos passar pouco tempo com a família
fazer algo que não seja tão relevante
assim para as pessoas e não precisa
trabalhar com um propósito maior desde
que com isso eu consigo ficar muito rico
isso é o que importa isso é o mais
importante é para isso que elas estão
acordando e indo trabalhar eu não tô
falando só de ir buscar o sustento para
a família o fato é que
é a grande pressão sobre nós uma pressão
para que a gente sonha alto e que a
gente queira conquistar muito a gente se
não é tão ambicioso sim por até ficar
confirmei queimado aí é um fulano
acomodado Hospital shows só entrevistam
pessoas que deram certo na vida e aquele
livro bem vendido a sua capa diz assim
sonhe Grande
É mas esse tédio aqui existe para trazer
opiniões diferentes sobre esse assunto e
a primeira delas é essa aqui eu não acho
que você devia sonhar grande
e é isso mesmo eu não acho que a gente
Deva sonhar grande
e eu não tô maluco Não hoje eu vim aqui
fazer um pedido que nem implorar por
favor não sonhe grande não sonhe grande
cuidado com seus sonhos
e repare eu não tô falando para você não
sonhar mas eu estou sugerindo que você
não sonho grande porque grande remete a
escala a tamanho a quantidade a uma
dimensão horizontal e a comparações que
nunca vão terminar quem sonha grande não
consegue se contentar com um apartamento
legal precisa ter uma mansão quem sonha
grande não fica feliz em comprar um
caminhão novo precisa ter uma Frota
sonhar grande implica em criar
expectativa projetar um futuro de algo
que tenha muito com muitas conquistas
com mais do que as outras pessoas isso é
sonhar grande mas não Qual o problema de
eu desejar algo grande tem problema
nisso veja bem eu não vim aqui para
falar para você sonhar pequeno ou não
é mas se você quer uma dimensão para
você poder sonhar eu quero te sugerir a
vertical
e sonhe alto
e sonha com coisas que tem profundidade
e relevância sonhe com coisas que tocam
no fundo da alma
as coisas que talvez sejam grandes
talvez sejam aparentes talvez não Mas
que ficam enraizadas sonho com sonhos do
alto para você
e esse sonhos podem ser grandes Mas ele
também podem não ser a grande busca por
propósito que existe hoje em dia mostra
que a gente sabe que tem um vazio dentro
de nós que não se preenche com dinheiro
nem com fama e nem com coisas eu entendo
essa busca e essa peça
é mas tem um amigo que te pressiona a
encontrar logo o seu propósito é mais
chato do que ter um cunhado crossfiteiro
ou entusiasta de marketing de pirâmide
bom e é por isso que eu vim trazer a
minha segunda opinião diferente aqui
para você eu não acho que você tem
encontrar o seu propósito hoje a busca
por um propósito revela que nós estamos
atrás de algo mais alto
e eu também já senti isso assim como o
garfinho
Oi Yasmim as respostas Vieram só através
do tempo e da Fé
oi linda não vieram todas elas Enquanto
não temos certeza do sentido maior das
coisas devemos continuar dando o nosso
melhor
e experimentando coisas nos conhecendo
observando e deixando os ouvidos do
coração bem abertos
aí a ficha vai cair
a nossa certa
hoje você vai descobrir que esse manual
na verdade não vem com todos os detalhes
escritos ele também não vem com uma
lista de tarefas para você fazer nem com
datas marcadas sabia
bom e talvez ele não venha com aquele
sonho Grande
é mas ainda assim você não vai ficar
frustrado porque ele virá com uma linda
missão para você
é como um sonho do Alto
o que vai te encher de verdade
e de significado tô querendo dizer com
tudo isso é que
e o seu trabalho ele não é só o seu
trabalho
e o seu trabalho não é um lugar onde
você simplesmente vai lá para trocar as
suas atividades por contas pagas muita
gente vê assim eu vou meu trabalho ou
troco meu tempo por dinheiro seu
trabalho pode ser muito mais do que isso
seu trabalho é um lugar aonde você
consegue pegar suas habilidades seus
talentos colocar em prática esse útil
para as outras pessoas enquanto você tá
trabalhando Você não tá só trabalhando
Você tá desfrutando de um presentão que
Deus te deu chamado vida
e o tempo passa rápido e você pode
gastá-lo Iva atrás daquele sonho grande
que talvez seja simplesmente algum
material que você viu por aí ou você
pode gastá-lo com algo que vai realmente
te encher de significado quem foi que
disse que não dá para gente ficar
contente como que a gente tem hoje
e quem foi que disse que não dá para
chegar em casa depois de um dia que
valeu a pena ter sido vivido sem ter
certeza das suas vocações e quem foi que
disse que a gente precisa conquistar
algo Grande para encontrar a propósito
na nossa vida Um dia eu também você
velhinho Olha só como você quando eu
ficar mais velha
e quando esse dia chegar eu quero poder
olhar para trás e imaginar que eu tentei
gastar o meu tempo da melhor forma
possível
e eu tenho ambições muitas ambições eu
quero tudo que a vida tem para mim tudo
nem um pinguinho ou menos mas eu também
não quero nem um pinguinho mais isso não
é uma competição quando eu bato as metas
recebo comissões polpudas
reconhecimentos e aumento são Dias muito
legais eu fico super feliz
é mas provavelmente Quando eu ficar mais
velho esses não serão os dias mais
lembrados
e o que foi que eu fiz quando aquela
minha funcionária falou que tava grávida
o que foi que eu fiz quando aquele
cliente não tava se sentindo bem o que
foi que eu fiz quando um colega de
trabalho não conseguia fazer a sua
função
e o que foi que eu fiz quando um
concorrente me ofendeu
e no fundo é por essas coisas que nós
seremos lembrados
é nesses momentos nós temos a chance de
colocar os nossos valores em prática e
deixarmos um legado de verdade um legado
Real São nesses momentos que nós podemos
colocar o amor em prática é amando que a
gente preenche nosso vazio
o e descobri que não importa o seu
trabalho se você fizer Elo da melhor
maneira possível sendo útil para as
outras pessoas essa talvez seja a forma
mais fácil de você amar as outras
pessoas não importa qual seja seu
trabalho mas faça isso intencionalmente
querendo dar o seu melhor para os outros
você corta cabelo você ensina crianças
você faz unhas você propõe leis Você
dirige carros para o aplicativo eu
preciso de vocês
E aí Você pinta quadros Você joga
futebol você escreve artigos que que
você faz
em qualquer uma dessas atividades você
tá fazendo a minha vida melhora mais
fácil mas gostosa
Oi gatinho você ajuda colocar comida na
minha boca
se você é muito importante para mim eu
preciso muito de você você tá presente
gatinho em momentos deliciosos em que eu
tô comendo com a minha família
se você não faz ideia da diferença que
você faz na minha vida
é garfinho
e atrás do que que você tá correndo
e quais são os seus sonhos quando você
sonha Você projeta um futuro E você
prepara a sua mente para aquilo
O que que você tá querendo gatinho
e se você tiver querendo simplesmente
ser mais rico do que a escova de dente
o uso de dizer que você nunca vai ficar
satisfeito mas se você entender que se
você quiser muito bem o seu trabalho uma
intenção certa
e você vai encher a sua vida de razão de
existir
e eu escolhi a história do gatinho o
dedo
é porque eu também trabalho no
Restaurante Eu trabalho no McDonald's
como você acha que eu vejo meu trabalho
agora Talvez você entenda a razão de eu
ir trabalhar todos os dias não é
e lá no Mac a gente tá batendo todos os
recordes de venda de Big Mac eu tô
felizão com isso porque mostra que a
gente tá fazendo o melhor trabalho
possível mas eu sei a gente não tá lá só
para isso instalar por algo muito maior
e a gente atende dois milhões de
clientes por dia e tem cerca de 50 mil
funcionários
e São pessoas que querem uma comida
gostosa rapidinha quentinha de qualidade
São pessoas que querem ter momentos
felizes são pessoas que querem
oportunidades
Oi e eu posso ajudar
e assim como o garfo faz
ah e hoje eu só vim aqui para fazer de
conta que eu sou um gás para você e vem
aqui trazer
é um serviço
E essas idéias como se fosse um alimento
Ah e assim como um garfo Eu espero que
você deu uma boa bocada
e esse manjar que eu estou de servindo
Hoje é mais gostoso do que o Big Mac
E aí tem gosto de amor
e o que foi feito pelo seu criador
é bom apetite e alto sonhos para você
é obrigado a